accueil chaleureux pour les candidats
socialistes surtout des plus jeunes pour
ce meeting le candidat et député sortant
de la 11e circonscription et attrapes
dans son fief
je pense que dans cette circonscription
j'ai besoin aussi de retrouver
l'honnêteté d'une relation avec des
habitants qui se passe de
l'intermédiaire des médias autant une
campagne présidentielle les médiations
important autant d'initiatives j'avais
très envie de quelque chose d'un peu
plus brut
une campagne législative difficile après
celle de la présidentielle cinquième au
niveau national avec 6% des voix
benoît hamon fait un peu mieux dans sa
circonscription mais loin des manuels
macro et jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour il est arrivé quatrième avec 12%
moi je veux bâtir cette nouvelle société
avec d'autres et ça commence par les
élections législatives on voit bien
qu'il va y avoir un démantèlement
méthodique du code du travail et des
protections des salariés
moi je me refuse absolument et mais pas
simplement pour dire non à ce que fait
macro mais aussi pour dire quelles
alternatives on lui propose et
l'alternative c'est la reconnaissance
par exemple du grand nocq comme maladie
professionnelle l'alternative c'est
privilégier la réduction du temps de
travail une meilleure articulation entre
le travail que l'on a et sa vie
personnelle plutôt que demain contre un
travail ou votre employeur décide des
conditions dans lesquelles vous serez
licenciés dans la salle des fidèles de
la première heure des élus de la commune
et des proches et va changer beaucoup de
choses il change il a des idées pour nos
jeux parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui n'ont
pas de travail traite pas cela il faut
leur cv et des comptes sur les cv il
habite à papa c'est fini il faut mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté toutes
les chances de leur côté pour garder
benoît comme député on en a besoin nous
sur travées sur la circonscription mais
je pense qu'on a besoin aussi sur le
plan national d'avoir un député de la
sorte qu'ils puissent faire entendre en
tout cas porter la parole de ceux qui
ont voté pour lui
pour ce premier tour 12 autres candidats
se présentent benoît hamon affrontera
notamment le 11 juin prochain
jean michel fourgous député de la
circonscription de 2002 à 2012 et nadia
et candidates la république en marche